l'espagne est officiellement devenu hier
le premier membre de l'union européenne
à franchir le cap du million de cas de
coronavirus alors que la restriction se
multiplient dans le pays pour contenir
la seconde vague de l'épidémie
le pays qui compte quelque 47 millions
d'habitants et le système au monde à
franchir ce seuil du million de cas
après les etats-unis l'inde le brésil la
russie et l'argentine
le ministère espagnol de la santé a
annoncé hier soir que 16 1973 cas et 156
nouveaux décès ont été enregistrés en 24
heures
depuis plusieurs semaines c'est la
rapidité de propagation du virus qui
inquiète les autorités comme les
médecins nous ne sommes pas dans la même
situation qu on mars
mais il ya un risque très important que
cela recommence ainsi nous sommes devant
un centre médical de quartier qui est
presque saturé
le personnel sanitaire a beaucoup de
travail est très fatigué les régions
prennent depuis plusieurs semaines de
nouvelles mesures pour tenter de
contrôler l'épidémie
des restrictions qui suscite critiques
et contestation après les restaurateurs
la semaine dernière ce sont les
étudiants qui ont manifesté ce mardi la
situation est un peu chaotique en ce
moment nous sommes sur un système de
semis présence mais les cours
présentiels se sont annulés durant les
quinze prochains jours et nous les
faisons à distance et on doit aussi nous
habilités des espaces privés pour les
cours à distance et finalement on nous
donne des salles encore plus petit que
les salles normal plusieurs régions
comme madrid ont déjà opté pour un
confinement perry métral c'est à dire
que les habitants ne peuvent pas sortir
de leur commune sauf cas de force
majeure le gouvernement espagnol
pourrait prendre de nouvelles mesures
plus drastiques encore dans les
prochains jours comme un couvre-feu à la
française